I'm John this is Kimberly we're from
Rockford Michigan which is just about 15
minutes north of Grand Rapids and I work
for consumers energy which is a electric
utility and we have four beautiful kids
and I stay home and homeschool the kids
and keep the little ones out of trouble
when we got married we both had student
loans from Cornerstone and we had the
ring on credit as she saw the truck
payment through loans were okay we
thought but we shouldn't have any other
debt so we decided to buy a house
because why not you know when you're
broke and everyone tells you you don't
throw money at rent somebody did with
zero down that's how we start out
marriage with like 40 grand and student
loan and consumer debt and a mortgage
that we had no idea she got pregnant
about nine months into her marriage so
that it wasn't a hundred percent plan so
um that was beginning of the wake up
call for me
we got the Total Money Makeover book I
think we had the book from the library
chief at that time and we're at it we
were hooked
so having financial peace and learning
that and reading the book and
learning Dave's tips and the right way
of handling money we talked to over and
says hey if we really buckle down
there's there's a small chance we could
pay these debts off this year so this is
our debt payoff that we used when we we
had this on our fridge there are no
secrets you came over you know what we
were doing and we just stayed motivated
by each time we made a payment we would
just write the lower amount and it just
kept us motivated to see how little we
had left I felt because I'm really crew
GLE I'm the one really making sacrifices
to keep our you know groceries down or
our eating out down so if I wanted to
spend something I'll cut a budget but
then John was like no no like we needed
so we had numerous fights because it
wasn't easy like it definitely was a lot
of hours I got a pizza delivery job at
Papa John's start working weekends and
nights and about a month or so into the
pizza delivery experience I got t-boned
at an intersection and it was kind of
that test like are we gonna keep going
are we gonna give up so we drove he just
did minimal repairs and kept driving the
truck it was definitely a crazy time in
our marriage but I think since we were
working so hard when we did have time as
a family we really made it count a year
and a half later we called you we had
paid off all our consumer debt in
October 2007 Wow
so after that point we bought oak street
is um with an estate property it had you
know what Dave Ramsey says the shag
carpet and terrible paint and whatnot
and thankfully we could just buy
painting changing carpet and get instant
equity so a couple weeks of hard work
and it was a lot better I just remember
that
like okay a fresh start another turning
point in our life what we can say we're
going to do different from now on so we
started buckling down trying to pay that
off we had $85,000 mortgage we wanted to
go very conservative because two years
later less than two years later July
2013 we were able to pay off our house
it was a big win for us to experience
the trials of trying to accomplish this
goal and play out sticking it out
together and being patient with each
other and loving each other through the
process because it is it's not as France
marathon that is very fun you're making
seventy five eighty thousand dollars a
year don't have a payment in the world
in thirty three years old I'd say this
is worked out
I feel like I grew in respect for him
because he was really taking care of our
family he was willing to deliver pizzas
or worked 50 hours a week when he could
be hunting or doing different things
she's a great homemaker a very thrifty
very organized and the real
encouragement to me to work hard and
we're on the same page we kill it
you're more likely to build wealth with
an encouraging supportive communicative
spouse where you're communicating
working together then you are any other
way and it's great for our children to
see like our kids saw sacrifice they saw
us pay off our house the more you focus
and follow this plan or you will win
because there's been times when we did
not follow the plan we lost hope we got
a little loose we didn't follow the
budget and we paid the price but when we
stuck to the plan it worked just remain
hopeful this isn't a sprint it's a
marathon
you can hold a hole and follow the plan
and just be faithful you may end up way
ahead of what you thought you were going
to be John and Kimberly from Grand
Rapids Michigan count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
you